[Música]
hola qué tal yo soy por lina cobos tengo
35 años y estoy aquí para contarte la
fórmula que yo descubrí para lograr mis
sueños y vencer los miedos
te cuento
el 11 de agosto del 2017 cuando yo tenía
33 años hace 2 años aproximadamente
estaba yo dormida era 11 de agosto a las
8 27 de la mañana entra una llamada mi
celular
y entonces suena el teléfono y contexto
y digo bueno
estoy hablando con paulina cobos si ella
habla de parte de quien mire estamos
hablando del ministerio público de león
guanajuato conoce usted al señor hugo
salvador fernández rodríguez sí claro
que lo conozco es mi papá no tengo sus
mismos apellidos pero si es mi papá en
que puedo servirle este fue el único
número de celular en su teléfono estuvo
usted hablando con él estos últimos días
verdad así es estaba hablando con él me
puede decir por favor qué es lo que pasa
con mi papá mire lo que pasa que
acabamos de encontrarlo muerto al
parecer de una sobredosis y raticida así
que requerimos que venga a reconocer el
cuerpo
durante siete años de mi vida estuve
viviendo de vender en la calle para mí
creo que mi abuela en el pueblo en el
que crecí creo que fue la mejor
enseñanza que me pudo haber dejado la
mejor herencia fue enseñarme a vender
recuerdo en el pueblo que me mandaba a
vender tamales me mandaba a vender
empanadas de salpicón me mandaba a
vender galletas postres calcomanías
etcétera ahí va a paulina la gordita de
casa en casa ofreciendo tamales
ofreciendo galletas etcétera
después cuando crecí salí del pueblo a
los 11 años me fui a vivir con mamá que
ella estaba trabajando pues para
sostenerme y con ella cuando estuve en
la ciudad más cercana que es tuxpan
veracruz estuve allá con ella y estuve
en ese entonces también ella me apoyo a
estar vendiendo etcétera cuando yo tuve
17 años 18 que entré a la universidad
genere muchísimos problemas con mamá
muchísimos mi ideología que yo tenía de
vida era muy diferente
de ella y honestamente aunque no me
enorgullece decírtelo puesto me una
elección que al final fue un parteaguas
en mi vida me salí a la casa y fue así
como terminé en la calle
de verdad eran tantas mis ganas de
querer salir adelante tenía muchísimas
ganas de tener dinero de ser exitosa
de lograr todo lo que veía que se veía
en la tele que se veía acá que se veía
allá y dije claro que puedo pero te digo
algo solamente tenía 500 pesos en ese
momento nada más hoy de 500 pesos no
había más con eso tenía que generar
tenía que ver qué hacía etcétera
recuerdo que unas amigas les pedí
permiso a quedarme a dormir en sus casas
pues en ese momento mi orgullo no me
permitía volver a hablar a mi mamá y
decirle mamá me perdonas me quiero
regresar a la casa llegué aquí a tampico
estaba acá y un día no armaba pulseras
aretes collares anillos etcétera con mis
manos hacia artesanía un día estaba en
casa una amiga agarré una mochila eche
todo esto la mochila tomé un autobús un
micro y me dirigí al centro
sabía que quizá muy probablemente ahí
podía vender mucho más porque yo ya
había cansado a la gente de decirle me
pueden comprar me pueden comprar osa ya
me habían comprado ayer entonces me fui
a el centro de la ciudad y en ese
momento que llegue de verdad recuerdo
los el estómago así apretado me sudan
las manos como ahorita entonces van las
manos del nervio se me están escurriendo
y empecé a caminar por el centro de la
ciudad de verdad es que eran muchísimas
las ganas que yo tenía de querer salir
adelante camine por la ciudad camine de
un lado a otro pedí permiso toque
puertas no me importaba en ese momento
que me rechazarán me juzgarán me
tacharán y hubo un lugar en donde
abrieron la puerta y me dijeron que me
podía poner ahí agarré mi manta que
había comprado la puse en el piso puse
cada uno de los accesorios que tenía
tenía bastante miedo y vergüenza porque
decir si me topo o alguien conocido que
van a decir de mí que van a pensar de mí
etcétera y fue así como empecé a vender
le fui perdiendo el miedo estuve
vendiendo afuera de universidades de
escuelas en ese entonces busqué rodantes
ferias carnavales de la zona expos
etcétera vendía y vendía y la neta es
que pues me generaba bien vivía bien la
pasaba bien pero después de tantos años
me di cuenta que estas ganas pues no
eran suficientes o sea definitivamente
por más de que tuviera ganas de tener un
buen de dinero por más de querer salir
adelante las ganas no eran suficientes
en ese momento empezó a red hacía
retumbar me en la cabeza una frase de
mamá que me decía cuando yo estaba
chiquita cada vez que le preguntaba a
mamá es que no quiero no sé qué voy a
hacer de grande no sé qué quiero ser
ella me la repitió pero muchísimas veces
y la frase dice así
si tú quieres ser doctor es el mejor
doctor si tú quieres ser barrendero es
el mejor barrendero si tú quieres ser
albañil es el mejor maestro de obra y
sea lo que vayas a hacer para nunca
nunca dejes de dar lo mejor de ti y
aprende siempre me decía aprende aprende
todo lo que puedas aprende todo porque
aunque crees que no lo requiere es quizá
algún día vayas a necesitar de eso esta
frase me daba vueltas y vueltas por ahí
de 6 años de llevar en la calle y dije
es que definitivamente requiero aprender
pero me preguntaba algo yo siempre había
escuchado en estos años
algo que hice mucho acá en méxico es que
querer es poder
y es que querer es poder y yo decía way
o si yo quiero o sea de verdad yo quiero
y quiero muchísimo y deseas que falta
algo a esta fórmula dije requiero
aprender
aún a pesar de que no me gustaba la
lectura y tenía la super hueva del mundo
agarre y empecé a leer empecé a leer
empecé a bajar videoconferencias de
internet empecé a seguir a famosos
exitosos que ya lo habían logrado empecé
a entrenarme hice entrenamientos de
coaching talleres conferencias recuerdo
por ejemplo unos libros que me
impactaron muchísimo que fue padre rico
padre pobre de robert kiyosaki los siete
hábitos de la gente altamente efectiva
de kobe quien se robó mi queso de
spencer o también que me impactó
muchísimo que me regaló mamá que ahí lo
tengo autografiado es el de ronda desde
secreto y todos estos libros mi mamá me
los había regalado de hecho muchísimos
años atrás y cuando me preguntaba ya lo
leíste pau ay sí ya lo leí planeta es
que sólo los hojeaba y los iba
acumulando entonces empecé a mejorar y
empecé a mejorar y empecé a mejorar la
fórmula llegó el momento en el que dije
ya estoy lista
fui toqué plazas comerciales centros
comerciales
un día en que en una plaza me abrieron
la oportunidad todos los ahorros que
tenía en estos siete años los arriesgue
le pedí prestado a mi mamá le pedí
prestado a mi pareja desde entonces
busque a mis amigos para que me apoyara
a repartir flyers volantes y que le
dijeran a su gente y puse mi primer isla
en la isla comercial vendiendo todo esto
de collares aretes pulseras etcétera
y me empezó a ir bien y cada vez me
empezó a ir mejor y fue entonces cuando
dije ya tengo la fórmula del éxito esas
ganas que yo tenía de querer salir
adelante
mi primera actitud más todo el
conocimiento que había estado
adquiriendo durante estos últimos 23
años desde entonces el aprendizaje más
hacerlo atreverme ser valiente arriesgar
todo por el todo acciones es igual a
éxito entonces
agarre y dije claro ya la tengo y le
empecé a hacer esta fórmula una y otra
vez una y otra vez tan es así que pude
lograr poner una otra sucursal otra
sucursal otra sucursal me convertí creé
un sistema de franquicias
me hice socio activo de la mf que es la
asociación mexicana de franquicias
y bueno todo eso me permitió generar
muchísimo dinero
me compré el coche de mis sueños la casa
de mis sueños que había yo imaginado con
la alberca pisé todas y cada una de las
ciudades que había querido estar estuve
en las maravillas del mundo me tomé la
foto perfecta me vestí de marca para
hacerte honesta también
y no me enorgullece la neta decírtelo
pero también despilfarra
entre en lo que fueron bastantes excesos
en drogas en alcohol en simplemente
comprar por comprar por sentirme a
alguien
la verdad es que en ese momento yo
quería demostrarle al mundo que ya lo
había logrado que ya era alguien que ya
podía
y en especial a mi papá
que no fue hasta los 30 años cuando yo
ya me sentía así suficientemente exitosa
que dije claro porque yo sabía que él
era un hombre exitoso en ese momento que
yo mi cabeza me decía tienes que estar
en su nivel para garantizar que no me
fuera a rechazar
lo busqué lo encontré por redes me metí
a internet le mandé un inbox
se tardó más de seis meses en
contestarme volví a enviarle otro inbox
y fue así como lo encontré
recuerdo que nos vimos en df
fue la única cita a ciegas que he tenido
lo vi en la central del df
lo conocí lo perdone le pedí perdón por
no haberlo buscado antes porque porque
yo no lo había buscado aunque él no
hubiera estado en toda mi infancia y
hasta esa fecha
[Música]
una vez que estábamos ahí me di cuenta
en estos tres años que me di la
oportunidad de estar conviviendo con él
me di cuenta que él de una u otra manera
tenía la fórmula del éxito así como yo
pero para serte honesta es que hasta esa
fecha hasta mis 33 años planeta es que
yo no era plena
la verdad es que los vacíos llegaban una
y otra vez a mi vida en muchos momentos
alcanzaba la felicidad bastantes pero
también mi egoísmo y miedo que
obviamente lo ocultaba para que nadie se
diera cuenta no me permitía ver ni hacer
conciencia que era lo que pasaba con mi
vida y me preguntaba bueno es que
realmente yo quiero vivir así realmente
es el éxito que quiero en todo este
tiempo tuve muchísimos fracasos
muchísimos te puedo decir que el 90% de
estos años fueron fracasos fracasos
fracasos pero tenía dos opciones
únicamente o culparme o victimizarme de
esos fracasos o responsabilizarme y
sacarle el mejor provecho y aprender
y llegó el día en que recibo esa llamada
esa llamada que te conté hace un momento
justo después de que colgué ese día me
di cuenta
separarme del tapete las vitrinas de la
calle los lujos de la humildad tan niego
no era el éxito que yo tanto había
estado buscando todos los años y
entonces me hice una pregunta para un
eta realmente quieres vivir así algo le
está haciendo falta esa fórmula esa
cuarta que le hace falta a la fórmula
que tú tienes y por eso es que hoy
quiero compartir tela
es el elemento clave y dice así actitud
más aprendizaje más acciones es igual a
éxito sigue siendo la falta a la cuarta
que yo estaba perdiendo que muchas veces
en mi vida yo sabía que existía dentro
de mí pero no me daba la oportunidad de
experimentar de sentir todo el tiempo y
entonces es cuando vengo y encuentro
este elemento la cuarta que te platicaba
actitud más aprendizaje segunda más
acciones más
y por amor es igual a éxito cuando hablo
de amor me refiero amor propio me
refiero a amor al prójimo me refiero
pero me refiero a perdonar me refiero a
ser agradecido
me refiero a aceptar los errores me
refiero a amar tu mejor versión me
refiero a contribuir con el mundo me
refiero a amar a la gente y dar una
parte de ti para crear un mundo mejor
y por eso quiero cerrar con esto
que tus sueños sean más grandes que tus
miedos y nunca olvides que todo sueño es
alcanzable a la medida en que tú lo
creas posible y que nunca nunca nunca es
demasiado tarde para hacer lo que
verdaderamente amas gracias de corazón
[Aplausos]